2014 is a special year for Russia.
For several years now, the country has been preparing for a most important event:...
...The Winter Olympics in Sochi.
Olympstroy, a state company,...
...has been coordinating the design and construction of sports venues for the games.
One-half of the facilities for Olympic events is located high in the mountains.
The other half is near the sea.
The distance between the so-called mountain and coastal clusters...
...is about 50 kilometers.
In this series, we will describe in detail the sports stadiums...
...located in the coastal cluster.
The Olympic Park is located by the sea.
This is an entire city occupying 256 hectares in Imeretinsky Valley.
The whole area is designed to accommodate more than 70,000 people.
The Olympic Park will be able to host 70,000 guests at a time.
The center of Olympic Park boasts a magnificent view of the six main sporting venues.